when Sushi counter opened its doors it
was committed to serving affordable
Australian style handrolled Maki in the
Big Apple where prices are typically
skyh High the public reported recently
however the restaurant has been
subjected to negative reviews by online
users who were put off by the fact that
the owner Alex is white one vocal Chef
Eric Rivera took to Twitter in a now
deleted thread to shun Sushi counter for
being owned by a colonizer white woman
suggesting that she has no place serving
the widely popular Japanese favorite
according to the public this deranged
standard is only ever applied to white
people and would never and has never
gone the other way you'll never hear of
a pizza place being bombarded with
negative reviews because it's owned by
an Asian guy or a burger joint being
protested because it's run by a you know
Hispanic woman you'll certainly never
hear anyone telling a black Chef what
sorts of Cuisine he isn't allowed to
cook based on his race